BUT RIGHT NOW LET'S TIME TO
PLAY BLANK HAD ME LIKE.
THE "HAD ME LIKE" MEME IS
THE EASIEST WAY TO EXPRESS
YOURSELF ON TWITTER.
JUST DROP IN WHATEVER TOPIC
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AND ADD THE
APPROPRAITE REACTION PHOTO AND
YOU GET --
NICKI MINAJ ANACONDA VIDEO HAD
ME LIKE --
SO COMEDIANS, WE'RE GOING TO
SHOW YOU A PHOTO FROM A HAD ME
LIKE TWEET AND FOR 250, YOU HAVE
TO FILL IN THE BLANK WITH WHAT
THAT HAD YOU LIKE --
ALL RIGHT, FIRST UP, FIRST UP.
THIS ONE HAD ME LIKE --
ARDEN.
>> LEARNING I WAS GOING TO
GROW UP TO BE KATHY BATES
HAD ME LIKE --
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
>> THAT IS MEAN.
>> CHRIS: JON.
>> AN ACTIVIA YOGURT, A
GIANT ICED COFFEE AND
TRAFFIC HAD ME LIKE --
>> CHRIS: YEAH, POINTS.
BESSER.
>> CHRIS: BILL COSBY DRINK HAD
ME LIKE.
I DIDN'T DO IT!
>> CHRIS: HE DIDN'T DO IT.
>> I DIDN'T DO IT I JUST
SAID THINGS.
>> CHRIS: HE DIDN'T DO IT.
>> ALLEGEDLY.
>> CHRIS: ALL RIGHT.
HOW ABOUT THIS FELLA, HOW
ABOUT THIS FELLA, HAD ME
LIKE --
>> WOW.
ARDEN.
>> THAT BAD MOLLY I BOUGHT
AT COACHELLA HAD ME
LIKE-- WHOA.
>> CHRIS: IS THERE A DRUG MOLLY?
>> IT IS ALL PEOPLE.
>> CHRIS: ALL RIGHT, I'LL GIVE
YOU POINTS.
>> IT'S ALL PEOPLE. ALL PEOPLE.
>> CHRIS: MATT BESSER.
>> BILL COSBY'S DICK IN MY
MOUTH 4 ME LIKE --
>> CHRIS: ALL RIGHT.
(APPLAUSE)
>> CHRIS: GUESS I GOTTA GIVE YOU
POINTS FOR THAT.
NEXT ONE. THIS GUY, THIS GUY,
HAD ME LIKE --
>> CHRIS: YES, BESSER, WHAT
COSBY EVENT?
>> READING ABOUT BILL COSBY HAD
ME LIKE--
(APPLAUSE)
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
AND FINALLY, HOW ABOUT
THIS TORONTO MAYOR, THIS
TORONTO MAYOR.
JON.
>> CANADIAN STRIP CLUB LAWS
HAD ME LIKE.
NO, BUT FOR REAL, YOU CAN TOUCH
THEM THERE.
>> CHRIS: UH, WHAT?
>> ANYWHERE BUT ONE SPOT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MATT.
>> SEEING THAT MUCH CRACK IN ONE
PLACE HAD ME LIKE --
>> CHRIS: POINTS. SO GOOD, MATT.
ALL RIGHT.